Hmm,
here's another thing that made me a
really an advocate of psychoanalytic
thinking.
It was the sort of thing that started to
terrify me about what the human psyche
was actually like.
I started to understand that not only
were we like an amalgam of,
of relatively autonomous
subpersonalities,
each of which had the possibility of
gaining control,
but that we're also victim,
you might say,
or beneficiary of impulses that were
beyond our conscious formulation or,
or,
or understanding or capacity to resist.
So here's this,
here's a funny story.
So I was talking to one of my patron
people online this week and he said he's
a,
he was a committed atheist and that's
fine,
you know,
lots of atheists are very honest people
and they're atheists because they don't
know how to reconcile what they know
with traditional claims,
let's say.
And they're not willing to just mangled
them together,
you know,
and there might be cynicism all that
associated with it as well.
But he said he was,
he said he was entranced by these
biblical lectures,
you know,
which is pretty weird.
And he said,
if someone would have told them a year
ago that he was going to be obsessed
with the sequence of Biblical lectures,
he would have told them that they were
mad.
And so we had a bit of a discussion
about that.
And because this is an interesting
thing,
you know,
and he,
he mentioned this,
he said it was something like,
you don't choose your interests.
They choose you.
And that's really worth thinking about
too,
man,
because you know it's really hard to get
interested in something you're not
interested in.
Even if you know there's a good reason
for it,
you know you're studying for an exam,
you find the material boring.
You know anything will be more
interesting than,
than this studying.
Even though you know that that's what
you need to do.
You can't voluntarily grab yourself by
the scruff of the neck,
let's say,
and shake yourself and say,
sit down and concentrate.
Your mind will just go everywhere.
But then if you're interested in
something,
and even if it's something you shouldn't
be interested in,
because that happens all the time,
then it's like you're a laser focused
man.
You can pay attention forever,
you can work until you're exhausted.
You won't even notice it.
Then you remember everything.
It's like,
okay,
if you can't control your interest,
what does?
And Man,
I tell you,
you can think about that for a very long
time.
So you talked about the spirit
Mercurius,
you know,
mercury is the winged messenger of the
Gods and,
and here's how he conceptualized it.
Psychologically,
he thought this is what the ancient
people who thought about mercury as the
winged messenger of the gods were trying
to state psychologically,
you know,
your,
your interest flits around.
It's like there's something that
captures it and that moves your interest
from place to place.
You know,
like if you walk into a bookstore,
you'll get interested in a particular
book.
It's as if the book grips you because
you don't know why you're interested in.
You might,
but often you don't know why you're
interested in that book and you know
your interest is flitting around.
And so that's mercury.
The thing that makes your interests
flick flick around his mercury,
the winged messenger of the gods and
mercury is the messenger of the gods.
Because it's the things behind the
scenes psychologically that are
manipulating your attention and for
young those were equivalent in some
sense to the last gods.
And so for young your,
your interest was being manipulated
behind the scenes by unseen forces that
were associated with your character or
logical development across time.
That was the manifestation of the self.
So the self is this,
the,
the potential you,
let's say,
and the way it operates in the present
is by gripping your interest in
directing it somewhere.
And that's part of the instinct of self
realization.
It's a mind boggling idea,
man.
Really it's.